apple just released a new short film ad
directed by damian chazelle the academy
award-winning director of la la land and
whiplash
i think this short film will be
interesting to examine because as far as
i know it's the first time a major
director like this has
shot a project like this in a vertical
format
vertical format is actually very common
these days we see it all the time on
tick tock or instagram and snapchat so
it will be interesting to see
what someone who has more experience
with
cinematic composition does with the
format
action this composition here is a great
early example of
how you can use vertical video in an
interesting way
chisel constructs scenarios where
movement is going from top to bottom
instead of left to right and this allows
him to use more of the frame when we
compose an image for film if there's
action we often want empty space for the
character or object that's moving
to move into so by using top to bottom
movement instead of left to right gisele
can utilize that negative space and have
action moving into it
in this shot the action is moving left
to right but
he uses the negative space at the bottom
in a visually interesting way it
emphasizes the height of the building
that they're on he's also creating a
frame at the top that mimics a wider
aspect ratio one of the key things he
did was selecting a scenario and a story
that works well
in vertical this shot in vertical
actually does a better job
of emphasizing in the available
composition
space the action that's happening here
but here we get two shots that show
ways in which vertical can be kind of
awkward and not really that great
in this one the action is moving across
the vertical composition and his hand
kind of
punches out of the composition for a
second and in this shot his eye is
getting cut off pretty awkward and i
don't think it really works
throughout the short we'll see chisel do
this several times he often uses frames
within
frames that mimic the vertical frame
this is an example of a shot that i
really just think doesn't work
in vertical the way the eyes are cut off
and the way it just
feels like it squishes and constrains
the face does not work for me i'm not a
fan
this section of the short is maybe the
worst part
i don't think he's utilizing the
vertical space as well as many of the
others that we'll get to
[Music]
here again he's trying to use vertical
movement to emphasize the verticality
but
he's not going all the way up here and
there's nothing happening down here so
this will work better as a smaller
boxier frame
[Music]
this is another shot that i think is
pretty awkward again there's just
nothing useful going on at the top and
the way the man's face keeps poking out
of the frame
is awkward this scene i think is where
it most feels like
giselle is just trying to jam
conventional images
into a skinny format and you can tell
[Music]
this right here on the other hand is a
really cool composition
the verticality of the space is being
emphasized by the
aspect ratio itself in this shot chisel
again
creates a frame within a frame that
resembles a
wider aspect ratio and here he uses an
interesting vertical frame within a
frame to draw our attention
inward and we think less about the
unused space at the top and the bottom
because of that
this is pretty good right here the
format feels pretty claustrophobic and
constricting and so
bringing in the sides even more is a
great way to utilize that
i also love the little pinpoint of light
at the top here and how
things are just constraining into a
little sliver
here chisel references a scene from john
ford's
the searchers in that film john ford is
essentially creating
a vertical composition within a more
normal
cinema frame using the door frame so
ford when he does it
is changing the aspect ratio when
chazelle does it here it's not
changing the aspect ratio but
complementing it
this section right here i think does the
best job of showing us
what vertical video can do a shot like
this
is just a really great composition using
the available space
isolating things like a single leg
using layers of action like this
this overhead shot to show distance when
chazelle
pushes things a little bit stylistically
outside the realm
of what you'd normally do with a
conventional film
he's able to utilize the space a little
bit more effectively these shots right
here like
isolating the hilt of the gun and
creating smaller frames within this
frame and the shadow it's
it's great i love this
vertical video works really well for
this kind of composition
a full body shot compare that to the
awkwardness
of the people sitting down in the car if
vertical video is something that gets
used a lot more for narrative production
it'll be
interesting to see how people come up
with ways to handle
people just sitting and talking this is
a much better version
of a close-up it's a little bit further
back and it doesn't constrain the eyes
so much but
i still don't think it feels great maybe
it's because i'm just not used to this
format but
obviously this kind of shot is not the
strong suit of vertical video
this kind of shot on the other hand is
here we get a great shot where it
isolates an eye
in half the face this to me almost feels
better than a shot that just
isolates an eye within a larger cinema
frame
one of the weird things about
composition is that sometimes they look
better when
the shape of the object you're
emphasizing matches the shape of the
frame
and sometimes it looks better when it's
contrasted here i think the
perpendicular nature of the shape of the
eye
against the vertical nature of the frame
actually works really well
great shot here emphasizing the vertical
movement of the sweat the super close-up
of the eye on the other hand i'm not
sure if that completely works
[Music]
this shot though is great by falling
backwards with him chisel here is
essentially taking what would be a great
composition for a normal widescreen
aspect ratio and using it in a vertical
aspect ratio
these are great uses of the vertical
frame
this right here is also brilliant this
is a great use of negative space by
anchoring things to the bottom
instead of just centering the
information in the middle
the dead space feels more like an
intentional compositional choice
one of the things chisel is doing is
using props that specifically
fit the frame obviously this car or the
specific mirror was chosen because of
its
verticality it's an unusual car mirror
but it works really well because of this
frame
this shot here is pretty cool but i
think potentially more could be done
with it
feels like the plane could maybe be
higher up utilizing more of the
negative space but because the action is
anchored to the bottom
i don't mind the negative spaces atop so
much and ultimately the way the plane
moves into the negative space at the top
is pretty satisfying
there's a little piece of set design
that's pretty interesting normally in
this kind of thing you might not have
such tall ceilings with a bunch of notes
up at the top but
that's a great set design choice to give
it more visual interest
again here chisel chooses a prop that
fits well with the format
because the theme is vertical cinema i
think gisele
is probably emphasizing the frame with
his compositions maybe a little bit more
than would be necessary if you were just
trying to
do something in a vertical format
narratively
he does use it well in a lot of
instances but i think this short also
showcases some of the shortcomings of
vertical video and how awkward some
things that feel
fine in a wider aspect ratio feel when
you slim it down
of course some of this is probably just
what we're used to
as audiences versus what feels unnatural
but
that's something for a long time anyone
who wants to
try to do narrative work with vertical
video is going to have to take into
account
it's going to take a while for audiences
to adjust
to this kind of content if it's
something that's used
more frequently that said the case study
for watching this kind of thing is on
your phone not on a screen so
there's a whole layer of considerations
that you have to take into account
there even aside from the aspect ratio
the intimacy of holding the frame and
the proximity to your face
is going to affect the way you want to
compose images as much as the aspect
ratio will
i think this kind of stuff will be more
common in the future could be the
laughable failure of a streaming service
had content that was available to be
watched
in both vertical and landscape modes on
your phone and while clippy's content
was terrible for a lot of reasons
other than that watching it vertically
wasn't that bad of an experience
and i could see creators like netflix
potentially trying to do things like
that in the future
of course composing both for widescreen
and vertical is a whole
mess on its own so that's kind of an
entirely different thing
let me know in the comments what you
think do you think chazelle used it well
or poorly what do you think works and
what do you think doesn't work this
video doesn't have any sponsors so if
you enjoy my content
you can help support my channel and get
access to bonus videos by going to
patreon.com thomasflight or you can go
to thomasflight.com
merch to check out the merch i have
available if you want to rep and support
the channel at the same time
thanks for watching hit that bell and
subscribe and i'll have a more
traditional video essay coming for you
soon